we are very excited to launch a new
series we're calling it never too late
it's a show to show you that it's never
too late for anyone to try something new
you agree with that right this morning
we're going to meet an Italian immigrant
who found internet Fame in retirement
during the pandemic he's become
something of an online star how he's got
cooking videos that have reached that
stuff looks good tens of millions of
people look at how it glistens Janet
shamlin went to his New Jersey home to
find out what he's got cooking in the
kitchen
it's clear retirement isn't on the menu
the Italian immigrant has become an
internet sensation with his cooking
videos
[Music]
a big this whole point with more than
100 million views on social media
platforms we've got the stove on already
it wasn't some Jeremy's idea some 14
years ago now you see the Sausage Shop
beautiful recording is Dad making family
favorites then posting the videos online
three two one go okay now you gotta go
New York 400 degree when he suggested
the idea did you think he was crazy
I say I think so I say who want to watch
me I I I'm at home who gotta watching my
house the hours of test all the time at
the wrong meat turns out people all over
the world they work it works for now the
videos are low-tech just a family style
production
from his own modest kitchen let's start
them with the sausage Pasquale learned
to cook as a child watching his mom in
Italy and I was in it my mother she was
a cook of sausage how old were you when
you when you learned this three four
five I'm a baby
as a young man he became a cook is this
how you rude your wife with food yeah
yeah you said my wife does she like my
food yeah when he immigrated to the U.S
in the 60s he took a job with the Long
Branch school district as a janitor it's
so beautiful this school this was his
first time back in 20 years did you ever
think when you were cleaning the floors
here many years ago that you would be
the star of cooking on the internet
today no and it was a thing so but I'm
so happy today what I I never was happy
like it today why Anna was like this
when I was young nobody was a look at me
no it's not cooked shrimp she's cooking
now no no this is raw raw shrimp no they
can't get enough let me ask you about
that famous video oh boy we come back
another this video one just star shine
yeah why just that shine one just shisha
one chest what do you think it is about
your dad that appeals to people I think
uh the whole thing that everybody why
they love him so much is because it
reminds them of somebody like whether
it's their father or their grandfather
or just somebody in the family like an
uncle
but who's 83 year old uncle has this
much energy
and Celebrity Status yeah every place I
go
I'll go to the store and the people
started oh I want to take a picture with
you do you say that
but the Simple Pleasures are where
Pasquale gets his kicks he's happiest in
his garden growing herbs fruits and
vegetables
on the right over here and in his
kitchen look at my chicken scarf a
beautiful look and now it's a time of
The Taste yes
is the very definition of a second act
what is your secret to staying young
first thing I got a young chicken my
wife
[Laughter]
she gave it to me everything bringing a
sense of humor and passion
to everything he touches
for CBS mornings Janet shamlin hello
Long Branch New Jersey
I don't know where Long Branch New
Jersey is but I want to go to your house
Pascual well it's not too far for me I
might have to go there oh God ever too
late as the series is called he can
teach you to cook I don't know I would
be a very good eater at his house
terrific I love his accent all of it
what did he say the key that staying
young was young chicken oh that train
has left the station for us oh no I
disagree Nate I have a very young and
spry wife and always will okay all right
Tony Nate you just wanted to recovery
you just want to get in trouble trying
to get Tony in trouble as you say to me
sometimes you should have kept that one
in your pocket